This time last year, it was full scale.
There were missiles.
There were tanks
coming down from the north.
There were paratroopers from Russia
who were landing nearby Kiev.
The siege of this city was being started
this time last year.
Then very quickly,
they pushed them back within weeks.
And now we hear from people that, yes,
they were terrified back then.
They did not know
whether their capital
or their country would be standing.
365 days later. It is.
And today
we had a press conference
with President Zelensky,
and I got to ask him a question
about how long
he thought this war would take
Mr.
President, I'm interested
in the timeline today on the anniversary.
You spoke to your own forces
and you called for victory
within this year.
You have heard the Western friends,
your partners talk about
as long as it takes.
You know that
the Russian leader believes
that time is on his side.
Why do you think that it's possible
by the end of the year?
And how do you assess
the meaning of as long as it takes
from your Ukrainian perspective?
Do the job losses over time?
Wasn't that your additional watch?
Thank you for the question.
Indeed.
I want to very much
If each of us, each partner
and we in our country,
if we stay as one fist,
one strong fist and work towards victory.
This is a victory of values.
If they stick to their words,
to their terms,
and it's not just blah, blah, blah,
I believe in it.
We have been partners, strong partners,
and there is evidence to that.
If we all do our important homework,
victory will be inevitable.
I am certain there will be victory
if
so, Brianna.
Last year, the watchword was weapons.
We need weapons to defend ourselves.
This year,
they say it's going to be speed.
We need them quickly
in order to be able
to actually launch counter offensives,
regain territory,
and somehow
get to the bargaining table
in a position of strength
so that they can have negotiations
to end this war
from a position of strength.
They will not surrender
and they will not take Russia's terms
right now, they say. Brianna.
All right, Christiane Amanpour,
live in Kiev. Thank you.
Our correspondents and experts
are standing by with more on this.
I want to start with you,
General Wesley Clark.
In a new article,
you right along with six
other former NATO supreme
allied commander, his quote.
Now is the time for America
and its allies to dig deeper,
to get Ukraine what it needs to win
and succeed.
And certainly,
this is something we heard
Christiane talking about that
the Ukrainians are calling for.
What do America and its allies need to do
and how could it change the
outcome of this war?
Well, the
outcome of this
war is probably going
to be decided at a negotiation,
but the negotiation outcome
will be reflecting
the battlefield conditions.
Ukraine needs
the wherewithal to put Crimea
under threat.
That means
getting through the land bridge,
threatening to overrun Crimea.
Putin will come to the table.
But to do that,
they've asked for 300 to 500 tanks,
another 500 pieces of artillery.
They need fighter aircraft,
they need attack helicopters
and for whatever reason
and long range missiles for a reason.
We're not giving them that.
So what we're heading
toward is some kind of a bleeding
or stalemate in which
I guess we think we're going
to get at the bargaining table
what we didn't get on the battlefield.
And history shows that's unlikely.
Jim, we know that Putin thinks
time is to his advantage.
He's trying to wait out the West.
Now you have this new intel
that China is considering
at least thinking about providing drones
and ammunition to Russia.
What are you learning?
Well, the concern is
and drones
could be impactful ammunition as well
because Russia has had trouble
getting ammunition as it continues.
An intense artillery battle
really on that eastern front.
Drones as well.
We've seen
the impact of Iranian
made drones there in terms of helping
Russia with its air war
on civilian targets across the country.
So the biggest concern from the U.S.
and Pentagon
perspective is that China's
help will lengthen the war.
It'll give Russia what it needs
now, particularly what it short of now
in terms of ammunition.
The other piece of that is more broad,
and that is that
you already have a war here
that is, in fact,
to some degree a proxy war between
the U.S.
and its allies and Russia.
You hear Western officials
don't want to describe it that way,
but you have the U.S.
and its allies on one side arming Ukraine
and you have Russia on the other side.
It's invaded
Ukraine with China deciding to provide
lethal assistance to Russia.
You would
you would
now have three superpowers,
in effect,
involved in the largest land war
in Europe since World War Two.
And that is a prospect
that speaks to the broader conflict
going on
between these superpowers,
really on a number of fronts
around the globe.
That could lengthen this conflict
and also adds a risk of escalation
beyond the borders of Ukraine.
Caitlin,
you had a really interesting interview
with Defense Secretary
Lloyd Austin about all of this.
Can you tell us what he told you?
Yeah.
This intelligence that I've talked about,
that China is potentially preparing
to do this, that
they're considering doing it.
They've cautioned to say that
they have not made a decision yet.
But it obviously raises the question
to what Jim was laying out there,
which is what are the repercussions
if China does actually take this step
We know what the consequences would be,
what it would mean on the battlefield,
but what would it mean for China?
And this is what Defense
Secretary Austin told me.
I think China, it
would be a very, very ill-Advised
step for China to take.
So would it significantly help
Russia, though, if they did that?
How much
how much of a blow
would that be for the Ukrainians
if Russia starts
getting that kind of assistance
from China?
Well, you know, again,
I don't want to
get into hypotheticals, but it's clear
that if
China has a lot of capability
in terms of munitions and weapons
and if they they provide the sort of,
you know, substantial support to Russia,
it prolongs the conflict.
And obviously,
that is the concern
there, that it could
prolong the conflict in Austin
told me, Brianna, that he the U.S.
has been delivering
warnings to China,
basically telling them
not to provide legal assistance to Russia
in this battle in Ukraine,
in this war in Ukraine.
But one thing we should note
is that Austin himself
is not delivering those messages
because he's actually not spoken
to his Chinese counterpart in much.
They tried to speak after the U.S.
downed that Chinese spy balloon.
The Chinese his Chinese counterpart,
the foreign minister,
did not take that call.
And he said
they actually have not spoken in months.
Something that is obviously concerning
that the Pentagon
chief cannot get his counterpart
in China on the phone,
not for lack of trying
but simply
because they're not picking up.
Yeah, sour relations indeed there.
And Jill,
Ukraine's head of military
intelligence says that Russia's goal as
they see
it is to capture all of the Donetsk
and Luhansk,
Luhansk regions
by the end of March,
even if Russia can accomplish that.
Do you think that that would satisfy
Vladimir Putin
I think you have to ask him,
Brianna,
what would satisfy Vladimir Putin?
And, you know,
if he really did take Brodsky and then.
Yes,
and that was kind of the original idea
that Putin had.
Maybe you could spin it
and say, you know,
we have these regions
but I somehow doubt that
that would be the end of it,
because even if they had those,
I firmly believe they would want
Putin would continue
to want to take over the entire country
or control it in some fashion.
Now, that could be
having a sphere of influence,
and that was his original idea,
to take Kiev, decapitate
the country
and influence it, take it over.
So I do not believe, sadly,
that he's
going to be satisfied with that.
And there are other things
that he can do.
If he had those two areas,
he could try to undermine
the rest of Ukraine
or he could create trouble
in the neighborhood.
And that is already
we're looking at Moldova
and other places where he could do that.
Right now,
General, we're seeing Russia continuing
to shell across the east in the south.
The Viognier group claims
to have taken full control
of a suburb outside of Bok Moot.
What will you be watching for
here in the coming weeks?
So the question is, how
effective will
the Ukrainians
be moving into the second line of defense
and inflicting casualties
and slowing the Russian rate of advance?
So for this
to work out on the battlefield,
Brianna, there's got to be a holding
in action.
And Don Bosch
and the Ukrainians have to be able
to create
and maintain
their mobile
strike force
brigades that they'll use to go south.
Apparently, that's the plan.
And the Russians want to
put so much pressure on the Ukrainians
that they can't maintain
the integrity of their offensive force.
So that's what we're watching for.
Can the Ukrainians hold and Don Bosch,
can we give them enough ammunition,
enough artillery?
And then is there going to be enough
left over
to make that counteroffensive thrust
toward Crimea
that would bring a successful
negotiation?
Jim, we're also watching tanks, right?
This first delivery of leopard
tanks from Poland
just arrived in Ukraine.
American Abrams tanks
will take much, much longer,
according to military officials.
Maybe next year,
well into next year even.
Is this going to be enough
to make a difference?
Well, the aim to General Clarke's
point is to give Ukrainian forces
an offensive strike
capability in affected.
And you've seen this with Bradley
fighting vehicles
that are already going in there,
as well as European versions of those.
Now, you have
German made leopard tanks
and Abrams tanks to follow
to give them the ability
not just to hold territory,
but to punch through as General
Clark was saying,
those lines to gain back
territory in the East End.
They have the ambition as well
of taking back Crimea.
When you speak to Ukrainian officials,
they believe they can do this
and they can do this
in the coming months.
You had the Ukrainian defense minister
speaking today
about the possibility
of winning this war,
including taking back Crimea this year.
Now, Ukrainians there,
they're confident in their abilities
and they've got a year
of incredible gains
in defense to work on.
I would say that U.S.
officials at this point are
I don't say more pessimistic
but perhaps more realistic
about how quickly
they can gain back,
particularly when you look at Crimea,
given the importance
that Russia places on that.
But these weapons are going
there for a reason, and that is because
it's not just Ukrainian intention,
but also the US US attention
to give them the ability
to take back territory and
not just defend it.